the CDC is advising the use of
non-medical cloth phase covering as an
additional voluntary Public Health
measures so it's volunteer you don't
have to do it they suggest it for a
period of time but uh this is
voluntary I don't think I'm going to be
doing it president Donald Trump took to
Twitter on Thursday night to reveal that
he and the first lady Melania Trump have
tested positive for coid 19 the
74-year-old added quote we will begin
our quarantine and recovery process
immediately we will get through this
together well it didn't take long for
Hollywood to weigh in some stars were
totally shocked by the announcement
While others pointed out several
instances over the past few months where
Trump ignored safety protocols and
undersold the pandemic as a hoax several
people including actress Kristen
Johnston brought up Trump's recent
comments at the first presidential
debate on Tuesday
saying they haven't aged well
specifically when he mocked Joe Biden
for wearing a mask I don't have I don't
wear masks like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask I've ever seen
anyway Alyssa Milano one of the most
outspoken critics of trump and his
administration and someone who
contracted Co 19 and continues to suffer
from its many complications actually
showed sympathy for the president quote
I can honestly say with all that I am
that I wouldn't wish this virus on my
worst enemy please wear a mask Kathy
Griffin replied to melania's tweet about
the news saying she may want to
quarantine until after Christmas while
Whitney Cummings joked quote I don't get
how Melania got it she's been social
distancing from Trump since they got
married Josh Gad called the news strange
and surreal and reminded people that
quote this virus can affect every one of
us from the most powerful to the least
meanwhile Todrick Hall joked that the
year 2020 is that big gift that keeps on
giving Trump got on TV mask shaming
Biden and defending his coid jokes and
now Trump and Melania have coid you
can't make this stuff up then he
reminded his followers of this moment
from the first presidential debate are
you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and to
say that they need to stand
down stand back and stand by quote
Corona virus stand back and stand by
Karma 2020 the first family's diagnosis
comes shortly after White House adviser
hope Hicks tested positive for coid 19
following several days of traveling in
close quarters with Trump on Marine 1
the president's helicopter Trump is now
among the estimated 7.5 million
Americans who have contracted the Corona
virus since March
[Music]